Golf Channel NBC sports reporter the
intrepid the Peripatetic Steve sands
Golf Channel NBC sports and you got the
Ryder Cup this week from France and that
starts Friday and goes through Sunday
but Steve was there he was in the
trenches he was there when Tiger Woods
came off 18 and got a chance to talk to
him Steve how are you buddy the captain
of the all loving team Dan Patrick good
to be with you know you're I'm captain
your MVP you're my Ryder Cup you're my
Ryder Cup captain when it comes to all
lobby bar let me tell you something just
like when I was an intern at CNN sports
in the late eighties and nineties I am
always your vice captain pal I
appreciate that
describe that feeling the atmosphere on
a team with Tiger yesterday I've never
seen anything like it
in golf and we do the Open Championship
Dan as you know and that's the only
event in golf where they have that scene
where the fans are allowed on the
fairway and go charging up the fairway
towards the green with the guy who is
eventually going to win or the person in
the last group and yesterday's scene was
spectacular and it was loud I mean it
was not golf loud and it was sports loud
it was it was amazing to see what was
taking place out there he was fighting
the tears could you sense that I did it
kind of surprised me I was I was not
thinking he was going to go that route
because normally you know Tiger doesn't
do that kind of thing I thought he
sounded more human that he's ever
sounded you could tell me Dan you're
probably watching as well I thought he
sounded more human than he's ever
sounded
I thought he sounded as humble as he's
ever sounded I think he understands
exactly where he came from and I think
now the fans understand exactly what
he's gone through to get back to this
point and what it meant to him to get
that 80th victory as far as comebacks go
and I know we love to categorise but you
know Ben Hogan came back from nearly
dying but this is Tiger with a lot of it
being self-imposed
but it's still a comeback and you know
as long as this has been to be able to
do what he's done how would you
categorize just how great this is
sports-wise well I think I I mean I
think it's the greatest or the largest
fall from grace in the history of sports
and now I think it's the greatest
comeback in the history of sports no
offense to Ben Hogan I understand he got
in the car accident and almost passed
away because of it but Tiger Woods is
literally the greatest player of his
generation perhaps the greatest player
of all time and for him to go down to
where he was not just personally Dan but
health-wise and then the issues he had
legally and then all the things that
have transpired and all the things that
have taken place I think this is the
greatest comeback in the history of
sports
now Tigers about winning majors Dan you
know it's not winning regular PGA Tour
events and saying that he's all the way
back so before we you know rub the
anointing oil all over the greatest
comeback in the history of sports phrase
I think it's an amazing comeback but a
Tony wins a major I don't think even
Tiger will tell you that he's fully back
his demeanor now as opposed to 10 years
ago oh it's a lot different I think that
one of the things that's fascinating
about these young guys and yesterday
Rory
you know crumbled under the awake and
wilted playing alongside tiger
Justin Rose did not play well at all
when he was trying to chase down Tiger
as well other guys have performed well
Molinari this summer was great to play
alongside him and Brooks kepta was great
at the PGA playing in front of him or
behind him actually trying to win the
PGA I think that one of the things
that's interesting about the young guys
Dan is that because of the way Tigers
demeanor is now versus the way it was
when he was destroying the spirit of
Ernie else and Vijay and and Phil
Mickelson and Retief Goosen and David
Duval in that group is that he's gotten
to know these guys and he's allowed them
to get to know him
so because of that he has a bit of a
softer demeanor with the other players
who are trying to beat him and also with
us and with the fans and we saw that
yesterday from Tiger he is a little bit
softer a little bit more congenial a
little bit friendlier with everybody and
and I think you know I think it's a good
thing it'll be interesting to see how
all of that transpires for him trying to
get back to where he wants to be which
is back in the winner's circle at a
major championship but for now clearly
he is a much more you know mellow person
to be around in and around the golf
course especially when he's competing
against the guys he's with it's amazing
to watch him he used to stone those guys
now you know that it was like what
blinders on and now he walks fairways
and walks off tee boxes and is talking
to the other players in his group it's
it's fascinating to watch Steve sands of
the Golf Channel NBC Sports joining a
stand Patrick show what's more
incredible that 10-year period where he
dominated or a ten-year period where he
didn't do anything
oh man the ten-year period where he
dominated in this sport is beyond belief
it's just so hard to win in this
forgiving example Fred Couples is in the
Hall of Fame Fred Couples won 15 times
in his PGA Tour career and won major
championship a couple of players as well
but 15 total wins he's in the Hall of
Fame he played roughly 30 years on the
PGA Tour again he's talking about a half
a win a year Tiger you're talking about
80 wins in his career now but for that
ten-year span you know you're talking
about something which 65 68 wins 14
major championships it's crazy
incredibly great to even grasp the
concept of having that 10 year period
the 10 year period would out a victory
over a major championship victory is
amazing but I'll always go with the
positive what he did in that 10 year
span was was beyond belief if Tiger
doesn't win another major does the
comeback matter
oh that's a great question the comeback
matters because he moves the needle so
much than that
it's it's incredible to me that there
has never been another athlete who has
moved his or her sport the way he does
the attention he brings the golf is is
far more than anywhere else in any other
sport we thought the NBA was gone when
Michael Jordan went away the NBA is
flourishing the NFL continues to roll
along baseball does great hockey does
great when it loses stars as well so man
that's a great question I think in his
estimation the comeback is almost
complete now that he's won a PGA Tour
event but I think when you are as great
as tiger and you set the bar that high
Dan I think major championships are how
he's measured and I think this story is
tremendous but I think the fairy tale
ending is him winning another major
championship great stuff you know yes
good questions hung in there and you
know I think your friendship with Tiger
certainly showed through in that
interview as well his respect for you so
safe travels to the Ryder Cup there
Steve we appreciate your time as always
anytime damn good to talk to you about
nobody likes us Steve sands golf channel
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]